a gentleman who does the color for the
Rams radio broadcast this was completely
astonished glad to have Daniel Jeremiah
now you Maurice jones-drew good to see
you well I appreciate it you know the
fight for LA where all everyone's in it
well it is unless and I guess whom
that's the LA football you'd like to
talk about right now you know I would
I'd normally probably plead the fifth
but I'm willing to take my lumps when I
have to so if we want to talk Bruin
football we'll do that as well no I mean
here's what we'll do is we'll just say
in our number one we went over the
schedule because daniel said he thinks
it could be a one win Bruins team which
is not which is not I don't know I mean
I feel like we can probably catch
Colorado we're down right now they may
take as little lightly we're getting
some players back from suspension so we
may have a chance there but we always
beat Cal I mean now it's the reason I
went to UCLA because we always beat Cal
that that's one of those things happens
you I mean you're you're mr. Northern
California so it's one of those and then
Arizona struggling right now and Arizona
State so I know her he's doing a great
job down there and they're recruiting
really well but I think after a couple
games these young freshmen that are
playing will be a little bit more
seasoned late in the year and then it's
always a great game when you play USC
both of us are down right now both have
freshmen quarterbacks playing so you'll
see some mistakes but I think we have a
chance at getting them as well
you believe in chip as of now i but we
have no choice but coming in I was very
excited about chip I thought he was
gonna come in and do some things I just
didn't know that all these players
weren't gonna play right away I mean
they have a talented team he had to come
in and change his culture and I
understand that I respect that so I'm
gonna give him a chance okay I think I
think we all deserve we all fans should
give chip a chance because he's trying
to change a culture there that he feel
needs to be changed alright now let's
talk about the team that you you call
action for the Los Angeles and I picked
them to winning the Super Bowl thank you
they are really terrific I think they
are the best team top to bottom super
nuts coaching staff roster in the
National Football League what have you
seen anything else on tape anything else
that I don't know about that theme or is
it just as advertised what we see on the
field right there you know I think the
one thing you can say and I was talking
with a Dale backstage everyone is is
selfless
they're gonna do their job and I think
when you have so many alpha males or you
people called dogs or personalities per
se like kendama kansui and donald todd
gurley guys with these Marcus Peters
Aqib Talib they've all bought into what
Coach McVeigh he wants to do and that
and that's that's real important for
this team because it could go down it
can go south real quick and that not
everyone bought in obviously with Aaron
Donnell hold out the way they handled
that situation was amazing to have
endowment consumed be able to take the
backseat and play a tougher position
than what he's normally used to then you
have receivers downfield blocking
linebackers or blocking linebackers in
the hole and Todd and I mean so they're
doing a good job and what Coach
everybody has done is everyone touches
the ball it's a very simple thing you
don't know who's gonna get it but
there's plays designed for everybody
touch the ball Jared Gault does a great
job of spreading the ball around and
defensively you know you have to get the
ball out quick or you'll get touched and
and you're receiving there's the corners
are smart enough to understand that and
and they play a certain way what do they
need to improve on what are they not as
good at right now that you think by week
eight ten twelve fifteen they could be
much better at Morrie's it has to be
depth right so when you spin the type of
mind the Rams of spin they don't have
the same depth like year five six seven
guys you have backups that are year one
two so those guys have a little bit more
experience because throughout the course
of soothing guys are gonna get hurt
you're gonna need guys to step in and be
able to make an impact either on defense
offense your special team so it's not
necessarily the talent that has to have
they have to improve on or just a
specific area in the game it's more of
just making sure you have a ton of
experience with the younger players that
are coming in making place obviously
wins it could be the answer here because
the win is the greatest deodorant the
NFL and it's also great it is the great
binder of teams but why is it worked so
well for Shaun McVeigh so quickly here
in LA do you think he can relate to his
players
yeah granted you know it's you have a
coaches 31 you have players who are
older than him on the team but he can
relate to those players in certain
situations where maybe older coach
wouldn't be able to relate to so social
media for example you know it's not as
if so tighter Twitter binds this team
understands that you know he understands
the Twitterverse I think and not just
that it's the the way the kids think
right
I can get I coach a youth football team
up north right and it's funny because my
son's on it and I'm trying to figure out
how to get to these kids and what's
going on and my wife is like well listen
they all play fort night which I don't I
play video games but I don't play fort
night so that she's like you got to
relate to those kids a certain way so we
play for B bucks which is a way you can
you know use money and different things
and but so it Maurice jones-drew
you're telling me that your youth
football team is more cohesive no
questions your wife said learn fortnight
that's right so I can relate to him and
I think coach McVeigh has done that that
that the same thing with his team as
well as Wade Phillips oh yeah like
listens beyond his weight Phillips
probably the greatest human being on the
planet right now a guy who's on Twitter
you know he says he loves Donuts all
these different things mom yeah right he
does a great job and he they what they
do is they they don't make their scheme
they don't make the player fit their
scheme they make their scheme fit the
player so for example Marcus Peters is
not a real press man guy he's off man he
likes to read the quarterback
well coach Wade Phillips says okay this
is what we'll do you don't have to play
press as much we'll play you off well
we'll switch our system so it fits you a
little bit more the same with Coach
McVeigh in his offense you know some
guys are do better things than others so
we'll make sure you're doing those good
things all the time Maurice jones-drew
here on the Rich Eisen show in a week
from today you'll be coming off your
broadcast as well as Fox coming off of
their television broadcast of the week
for kickoff between the Rams and the
Vikings in the stadium where the
Chargers play the Rams this weekend are
the Vikings a team that is built to give
the Rams the most trouble in the NFC
like which team do you think is built to
give the Rams the most trouble the
Vikings the Vikings definitely one with
the addition to Kirk Cousins I mean last
year the Rams went up there and D that
defense was no joke and so they know
that going forward the Rams were still
growing in the first year of mcvane is
that one way you could put it or they
were already the team that they are
today I feel like they were the team
that they are today I mean grand they
have some different pieces but
offensively that that they went down and
scored on the first series and then
after that they didn't there was nothing
yeah right so that's a team that you
know it's strength against strength
where that defense is going to step in
and make some plays
I just think now there are better
defensive team than they were
so their defense is going to allow them
some room to you know where they had
they don't have to score every time they
don't have to score 30 points they can
go out there and maybe score 28 21 maybe
have a bad couple series maybe a bad
first half like we saw in Oakland and
then that defenses allows that offense
to bounce back but you still have Philly
who's really good and they're banged up
right now but they'll get healthy as
well as the Packers I mean it you this
is be honest when twelves on the field
it doesn't it just I got one for you how
about the Jaguars how about what about
the team in Jacksonville yes built the
way they are defensively built the way
they are offensively to possess the ball
and if bortles plays the way that he did
against the Patriots that might be a
Super Bowl team right there so I don't
know if you my Super Bowl predictions of
Jags Rams and this for selfish reasons
could I get a ring either way right so
I'll finally get one when that happens
I'll finally get one but the what
Jacksonville has done and I've been
obviously covering them and going to
their training camp that defense is
amazing and they find ways to do
whatever they want defensively to play
the Giants and you know contain Odell
Beckham granted they didn't stopping at
a hundred yards but then they come back
and go against Gronk and literally shut
Grunk down and get the time the way they
want to then I felt like forcing the
Patriots to find a receiver after that
point and making them go and trade for
Josh Gordon shows that the Jags are
doing something right offensively Blake
bortles
you know there was a comment from Jalen
Ramsey he had a lot of comments it's
offseason but I think the best comment
he had was last year Blake didn't try
the D B's deep he didn't do that he'd
that what he was stayed away from him in
practice this off season throughout OTAs
and through our training camp he tested
him and they made plays as a defense but
he also made plays in offense will help
build his confidence because he goes I'm
not going against general Ramsey every
week so you're seeing those go balls
that they were throwing and those
receivers are going up and getting
because they do that in practice every
day against arguably the top secondary
in the league do you think Josh Gordon's
gonna work out a new way yeah I think he
will if he's a viable player I mean we
don't know what's going on off the field
with him if he's oh we're assuming if
New England hired him that whatever's
gone on
crawl off the field is something that
they feel they can either deal with
handle or or not yeah well I think there
are certain players there every player
is different and so you have certain
rules for certain guys guys like Josh
Gordon a palma if I'm an owner if I'm a
team I'm gonna make sure I put someone
around him 24/7 and we're gonna make
sure we have a guy pick him up from home
take him home after practice make sure
that you you because again his a talent
his abilities kind of worn that right so
it's like okay we know he could play on
the field we just have to make sure we
take care of them off the field so you
have to use the resources of the
community make sure you have people
watching him and helping him when he
needs different things don't allow him
to have idle time and we all know the
the saying is idle time and all that
stuff so I think that he has abilities
and I know Bill Belichick would do a
great job with them and Tom now has his
deep threat I mean that guys the size of
a linebacker running for three down the
field and playing on DBS I mean it's
gonna be a tough guy to stop regardless
so do you got Jacksonville you've got
New England you've got in the West the
way the Chiefs have looked obviously
yeah they've got the Saints you've got
some teams that are that are that are
gonna be one would think progressing
moving forward the men you got the
Steelers who are oh one on one now look
look this is the first time I think in
the regular season where we're not even
in the media even expecting to see
Le'Veon Bell or we're keeping our eyes
peeled or our ears to the ground here
but he's not coming in through that door
but the way that you're smiling you
share an agent do you know something we
do share an agent and I've spoken to him
I spoken to him a couple weeks ago yeah
again this is you know I wrote an
article about it and we talked about it
on a game day morning but you know this
is the NFL has to understand that you
know you can't place everyone and you
can't put square pegs in a round hole
you can't do that you can't just say
he's a running back so he has to pay
this much when he has been you know 50%
of your offense or 40% of your offense
it's been a dual threat for you lay
beyond is a very smart businessman and a
lot of people may not see that but he
understands his Worth and he had to
weigh his options with you
do I go out here and I get 30 carries in
week 1 30 carries in week 2 30 carries
in week 3 and then possibly be worn down
and not be able to get my max maximize
my potential and free agency or do I sit
out with the franchise tag by not
signing and not getting fined you know
yes he's losing money each week but I
think he weighed those options and so
we'll wait to see when he comes in but I
now we see that lay beyond is a bigger a
bigger part to this Pittsburgh Steeler
team than a lot of people thought well I
mean the answer is as well though he
doesn't play defense and the defense has
been horrible but with a difference
between him and James Connors James
Connors not lining up in the slot
creating all sorts of matchup problems
on Sunday were there whenever they play
and keeping defensive coordinators up
with that prospect all week long that's
that is without question his
differentiator his fingerprint as to as
to why he's as great as he is the
question though I have for you as well
is that you know your mutual agent when
the whole long term agreement fell apart
on the July 15th deadline said that
levian was still going to come in well
he did say he did say that he blitz
pâtisserie he intimated it would be the
same thing they'd run it back from last
year that he'd be there from Joe Street
on barring something extraordinary so
something extraordinary happened what
was it the Gurley contract I think it
was I think it was the Todd Gurley
contract I think it then was after that
the players speaking out I think it then
was after that saying David Johnson's
contract and you know that the
difference in guarantee so for all our
listeners and people that are watching
as a running back you don't look at the
total number so it may be 80 million
dollars as a running back you don't see
majority time running backs don't see
that I think Adrian Peterson signed a
hundred dollar deal and didn't see all
of it only got three years of that so
you focus on the guarantee because our
position is so so brutal it's so tough
you get hit every play the Steelers are
offering lay beyond 19 million
guaranteed that's I don't think that's a
real good number one you see David
Johnson sign at three and they were
signing a four or five-year deal with
that where David Johnson signed a
three-year deal for 30 and then Todd
signs a 40
five million dollar good like is it that
becomes what we call disrespect
sure absolutely but to start torching up
850 thousand dollar checks each week and
that's money he will you could say he
now hold on a second I I know you I know
what your response is gonna be money
he's never going to get back but if he
does keep the tread off the tires he
would be able to last longer into a deal
and see more of that back-end money that
people like Adrian Peterson did not see
but that's not a guarantee yeah it's
really not but he had the way there's
the way these options right and so
obviously he chose to sit out and wait
it's it's funny because when when you
say it I have buddies that come like man
I can't believe he's given up eight
hundred and and it's a it's a crazy
number to think about as a crazy number
but the numbers in NFL is so crazy like
even now I'm like dude like he's making
that number is like twice as much as I
was making when I was playing or more
than that way more than twice but it's
just that's just the way the league's
going he deserves more than that though
and I think he understands that he's
earned more than that he's done the
things necessary to do that people are
gonna talk about some mistakes that he
made as a younger kid well there's other
players in this league that have made
mistakes as well and they still gotten
paid and so wait again this is this is I
want people understand like this is
literally business at its finest this is
the NFL's 11 billion dollar business and
you have players who are businessmen you
have owners who are businessmen you have
to respect both sides and I think over
the last couple of weeks you're starting
to see that kind of way out a little bit
where people like ok now I understand
why he's doing this because you see week
one right out they come in they give
Connor James Connor 30
I know 37 Delta's that's like that
attire that he wants to avoid I
understand but it's also tough to like
people are seeing loving I'm billing up
thinking MBA they're seeing TMZ it's a
nest it's an interesting way that he's
spending his time away from the team
he's a he's a he's a music artist as
well and he has you know he has other
things he's doing other things as well
he's still training and staying you know
it's great he's oh so week 11 an article
saying I wouldn't show up till week 11
if I could do my holdout all over again
I wouldn't have shown up to week 11
that's me
sharing that
obviously after I did it I don't know
when he's gonna come back I really don't
know I I've tried to pry it out of my
agent he won't he won't spill the beans
but he has to show up but he he will
show up yeah I mean at some point for
the business part of this right get
where he wants to go exact complete
freedom he will be he will be playing
for the Pittsburgh was 11 for sure he
has to show by the end to be ordered in
order to be a free agent for next year
again you know to go back to Pittsburgh
I know we talked about their defense and
yes they need to make some plays where
actually your injuries huge part to that
mm-hmm
but it just seems like their ladies got
a lot going on right now in that locker
room and I know Antonio Brown really
well and he hates to lose just like a
lot of players like Odell Beckham hates
to lose and a lot of players that they
dislike losing they just got to find a
way to get a victory and kind of get
this thing about going because they're
still a really good team I mean I saw
him in training camp they're flying
around offensive ly defensively they
just got to hold some guys you can't the
Chiefs are no one thought the teeth were
gonna do what the Chiefs are doing it's
so exciting though they're so exciting
this kid is so exciting right at the
trigger and Tyreke he'll I mean he is
dynamic kelsey hahn and let me walk it I
mean Watkins had a very nice day in
Pittsburgh as well that's just so much
fun ask the poll question of Maurice
jones-drew before we leave before he
takes off all right better man I felt
total access tonight MGD looking at two
no teams yeah which is the most Fugazi
Bengals Broncos Bucks dolphins
yeah I'm gonna go with the Dolphins why
I'm just not a believer in Ryan
Tannehill I just I just haven't been he
starts off well but towards the middle
is easing kind of tends to go down a
little bit the last time they went to
the playoffs uh Matt Moore was the the
quarterback that met won some games late
in the year to help him get there and so
I just have to see more of Ryan tan oh I
haven't seen enough of him and I know
he's been the league like six years but
we haven't seen enough consistent play
from him to warrant that they are a team
that's gonna be in the runnings late in
the year and you mentioned Saints I mean
is that team you like you like them too
you think yeah I think once Engram comes
back they can get their running game
going camara doesn't have as much on his
plate and then he can kind of focus on
his certain package and plays
um defensive they have to they have to
figure it out defense but I thought they
did it a little bit against the Browns
but you can't give up that bomb on 4th
and 5 to Callaway you can't do that at
all so they got some issues they they
have to work out but it's funny Sean
Payton doesn't hold anything back and an
offensive though they'll be fine
known that Callaway man I mean he's a
weapon fort Baker Mayfield before I go
before you go I give you a slore and
what you saw last night from him what I
saw first of all bit I'm a big Tyrod
Taylor fan right so it was sad to see
him go out I went out but Baker Mayfield
showed great poise in the pocket they I
love the way that Todd Haley adjusted
his game plan for him a lot of coaches
aren't willing to do that they try to
force their game plan on you but how to
go how did he adjust it for him they
started give him a little bit more rpoS
that that run-pass option they were in
shotgun a little more tempo he came in
in two-minute drill where he's
comfortable at what he ran in college
and then he was making throws and I
thought after first couple plays of
two-minute drill he got and he got real
comfortable throwing the ball in between
the hashes and throwing strikes in
between the hashes and making throws and
giving his guys opportunities and then
his guys were making plays for him so he
came in with a lot of confidence came in
with a system that's geared a little bit
more towards him where I don't think
Tyrod was running our POS he's more
running a more pro style offense but it
works for him and that's the key as a
coach you have to do what it's best for
your player and to see Todd Haley go
away from what he did in Pittsburgh what
he did in Arizona what he did in Kansas
City to more of a college cell offense
where they were running a lot of shotgun
runs getting the ball out on the
perimeter
quick quick drops things like that
helping him just get adjusted I thought
he did really well and so I think
they'll keep him proven off that as the
season goes on and you listen they won a
game and he's the reason they want it so
do you think they'd be through you know
if he started the season I think they
would be throwing out their kicker could
make a feel though do you think that the
Steelers would be three and off levy on
bail was active and on the teens and
paid whoo and happy oh yeah yeah I think
David it would be a different it would
be a different game if Lady Anne was on
the field and everyone was happy because
this again the answer in Pittsburgh that
people say is he doesn't play defense my
home still with a carved him up they
didn't play defense lash and I went 13
and 3
I mean their defense was okay shazier
did some good things but they still were
able to make runs the locker room this
is something for everyone to understand
- football is played in the locker room
it's not like the coaches can call
whatever play you want but if the
players in the locker room are
comfortable with and they execute it and
it's not a I don't want to call it if
their locker room is tight and cohesive
and they they know what they're doing
they're fine right now you have a lot of
stuff going on that piss-poor locker
room you have a lot of people with
different opinions about different
things that are very vocal and they have
to fix that first and I think that was
one thing that I learned in Jacksonville
is that how important that locker room
is because we're all on the same page
you're gonna win games you see this this
team how they black up Blake bortles
when people talk trash about them you
see how they're able to respond when
Leonard fournette goes out I think if
you look at the Rams locker room the
same way you don't hear a lot of
nonsense coming out of their locker room
you don't hear a lot of anything coming
out of the locker room but positive
stuff about what what they have to do to
play the next game or how they feel
about their teammates the locker room
was really important so you have to fix
that first before it starts to translate
on the field well I don't know what what
what numbers greater number of
controversies in the steelers locker
room or a number of different twitter
handles that maurice jones-drew has had
since joining Twitter you're now a Dem
JD yeah very simple now he used to be at
jones-drew 32 they used to be tons of
underscores and places now you're just
flat out at em JD so well I had to go to
thank got to go to a higher place
wellmaybe McVeigh's got that straighten
out since he's such a great Twitter guy
and now but you're now that you've got
your finger on the pulse of your your
youth football team we're trying to want
to try to win the next game you're a
millennial Maurice jones-drew what can I
tell you enjoy the weekend
oh call on the Rams games you do great
job that I hear you driving around town
and we'll see on NFL Total Access
tonight at 70s yes Maurice jones-drew
right here on the Rich Eisen show when
we come back sneaky good games in my
unlock iasts lock of the week will sneak
in some more phone calls at 844 to
hateful for 204 which by the way my
unlock is lock of the week I'm one on
one I got one right I said the Browns
are gonna beat the Steelers I did that's
to be a victory though they didn't lose
yeah I'll take that but I guess the
metric is if they're not drinking beer
for free they're in Cleveland it's not a
win now we all know that
Maurice jones-drew here on the show
we're back with you in a moment the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience